welcome to the second Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I discuss how to cut
weight for powerlifting how to train
during a caloric deficit the
acceptability of putting pineapple on
pizza and much much more remember if you
want your questions answered on a future
episode check out the links in the
episode description below thanks for
listening and enjoy the episode this is
your host Eric Trexler with temporary
guest host Greg knuckles and we are
ready to roll tonight we just got back
from a second-place finish in trivia a
lot of unforced errors probably should
have pulled out the wind but second is
better than usual for us so we'll take
it but right now I've got the perfect
mixture of diet cokes and IPAs in my
system and I'm ready to answer some
questions
how you feeling Greg feeling good
alright let's get into it
first question by one Pierre my question
pertains to both true strength 1 to 5
reps and getting stronger in the 812 rep
range very judgmental use of the term
true strength there yeah very dismissive
of higher rep ranges yeah so he
continues according to what I currently
know these training parameters elicit
certain fiber types and energy systems
to be more dominant during their own
phases my question is due to those
differences is there any carryover or
need to develop strength in the 1 to 5
rep range in order for that strength to
be carried over into the 8 to 12 rep
range the way I see it is that getting
stronger in the 8 to 12 range would have
better returns on hypertrophy compared
to first getting stronger in the 1 to 5
rep range due to these energy systems
requiring different stimuli energy
systems and fiber types oh man so
there's there's several layers to this
one assumption here seems to be that
different rep ranges train different
predominant fiber types to different
degrees and another assumption seems to
more or less be that
getting stronger will either cause you
to get bigger or at least help you get
bigger so I'm going to first address
those two assumptions the assumption
that getting stronger will help you get
bigger I don't think is honestly that
well supported so there is a pretty good
rationale for getting bigger to help you
get stronger
just as you hypertrophy especially
myofibrillar hypertrophy you gain more
contractile tissue that should help you
produce more force lift heavier weights
so in terms of like that that
directionality getting bigger should
help you get stronger in terms of
getting stronger helping you get bigger
I'm not I don't think the experimental
evidence really supports that so if you
if you conceptualize of strength as kind
of an interplay between structural
factors which would primarily just be
muscle size but architecture may fit in
there a little bit as well because that
can adapt with training maybe like soft
tissue adaptations if you look at it as
an interplay between those factors and
like neural factors with strength
basically being the product of those two
things then like essentially I don't I
don't see a good reason to then assume
that getting stronger is going to help
all of those other things like they like
or at least like developing further
neural adaptations will help those other
things as long as your nervous system is
to a point that you can actually recruit
all or most of your motor units and take
an exercise close enough to failure
before foreign breaks down that you can
like stimulate most of the muscle tissue
I don't think I can't think of a strong
argument in favor of neural adaptations
from low rep training helping with
developing further muscle mass and I
don't think the experimental evidence is
really there to support it either if you
look at the research on like comparing
high load and low load training people
get way way stronger if they train with
heavier loads versus if they train it
like 30 40 percent one rep max
but the hypertrophy seems to be pretty
similar so so I just don't necessarily
think that getting stronger is going to
help you get bigger I think more so if
you're training for hypertrophy you will
also build some strength just as an you
know a natural byproduct of accruing
more contractile tissue but I think the
causality there is primarily getting big
helping you get strong and not
necessarily getting strong primarily
here being neural adaptations
necessarily helping you get bigger then
the other assumption being that
different fiber types contribute more or
less two different rep ranges and
different styles of training there's
also not great evidence for that the the
only really clear strong evidence I've
seen that I actually trust is from a
recent paper out of I believe Norway one
of those Scandinavian countries but I
believe Norway where they had power
lifters do dedicated blocks of low load
training with blood flow hypertrophy and
they saw pretty clear preferential type
one fiber hypertrophy in those studies
the next strongest evidence probably
comes from a Russian group two main
researchers they're being met Reba and V
no grade OVA and there's I don't
necessarily want to get into it too much
here and now but there's some there are
some methodological issues in those
studies and there are some issues in the
methods that I simply don't think are
physically possible so I'm I'm very
skeptical of those studies so so
basically the there is very scant
evidence that like fiber type specific
hypertrophy with different rep ranges is
an actual thing and the strongest and
most direct evidence that we do have was
on a specialized population power
lifters who you know maybe have a crude
preferential type to fiber hypertrophy
over the years
from doing like very very specialized
training and maybe could get like some
ketchup growth and their type 1 fibers
but but that's like that's a very
special case
compare that to a study by Morten nettle
where they had people trained but more
like intermediate type lifters training
in the 8 to 10 repres is like 20 to 30
rep range that study found really no
preferential fiber type hypertrophy at
all like similar growth in both the type
1 or similar growth between groups and
type 1 and type 2 fibers so yeah like
I'm still I'm still skeptical of like
different rep ranges affecting different
fiber types differently in terms of
growth I'm skeptical of that whole whole
idea being true in the first place
except under like special circumstances
so my my thought here is kind of that
you may just be overthinking it I do
think that strength in the 8 to 12 rep
range is a decent proxy for size
assuming you're like controlling
training variable so you know if you do
a block of powerlifting specific
training where volumes not crazy high
but intensity super high and you get
some neural adaptations that bumps or 1
rep max up now that pumps your 8 to 12
rep max up maybe you're not going to
gain much size in the process doing that
but if you're training mostly in
moderate rep ranges and you're also
getting stronger and moderate rep ranges
the assumption there is you're not doing
specialized training that's going to
cause a lot of additional neural
adaptations so their gains and strength
will be more just kind of reflective of
continued increases in size and so so
basically to answer your question one no
I don't really think you need to do low
rep training to boost strength in an
effort to increase size and I don't
really think you need to worry about
fiber type specific adaptations in the
first place I think that that basically
if you want to cover all of your bases
do
the majority of your training like you
know between 2/3 and 3/4 in the
traditional hypertrophy range of maybe
like 6 to 15 reps per set if if you
think that maybe the low rep stuff may
be better for type 2 fiber hypertrophy
like yeah whatever throwing some triples
from time to time if you think that the
really light higher up stuff may be a
little better for type 1 fiber
hypertrophy like sure throw in a couple
sets of like 20 bicep curls or knee
extensions or something at the end of a
workout but for the most part I think
that yeah like strength gains in that
moderate rep range are more are fairly
reflective of increases in size as long
as that is where you're doing most of
your training and I don't necessarily
think you need to to overthink it too
much past that point and just to clarify
you're basically saying no one's missing
out on hypertrophy leaving gains on the
table because they neglected the lower
rep ranges but that doesn't necessarily
mean someone can't achieve very good
hypertrophy using those those lower rep
ranges right oh for sure yeah I mean I
mean I I think like on a per set basis
you're probably gonna get a little less
growth from training and lower rep
ranges like you certainly can still grow
it's just going to be a little bit less
efficient and so you know take more sets
more time in the gym
yeah yeah you're gonna if if you want to
get a similar hypertrophic stimulus from
the entire session it's probably going
to take more time in the gym to do that
or if you're like 'ok waiting for time
in the gym you're probably going to get
a little bit less growth per session but
like if you if you like training like
that it's still perfectly fine but yeah
you you probably shouldn't then assume
that if you do a block of powerlifting
specific training and you get stronger
and they 8 to 12 rep range as you're
doing that that that's necessarily
reflective of a bunch of additional
hypertrophy so i've got a brief anecdote
i know the Q&A episodes are all business
so please forgive me but i did a a
dreamer bulk when i was in college and a
dreamer bulk if you're not
with the terminologies when you get fat
as hell and convince yourself that
you're actually putting on a ton of
muscle and the lie that I had genuinely
believed and talked to myself into was
that as I was gaining this weight
because my max deadlift kept going up
and up and up surely these were very
very lean gains because look how strong
I'm getting and this I was very young at
the time and very very stupid and it
wasn't until one day my roommate was
like hey Eric I just wanted to let you
know that I've noticed you've become
quite fat and I don't know if anyone
else is honest enough to tell you but
you should really reconsider the way
you're doing things and so Nick if
you're out there thank you for having
the courage and the warm heart to tell
me that I was looking like a mess but
yeah it you got to be very very careful
when you're trying to use strength as a
proxy for hypertrophy like you said it's
got to be very specific circumstances
where you can actually make that leap
and in terms of trying to correlate the
two yeah and and just to reiterate one
more thing the idea that training and
different rep ranges elicits specific
hypertrophy of different fiber types so
namely that training with lower rep
ranges is going to cause more type to
growth and training with higher rep
ranges is going to cause more type 1
growth like I said that that's something
that people assume just based on the
fact that type 1 fibers are less fatigue
able so maybe they're going to be a
little bit more involved in like high
rep stuff and vice versa with type twos
but I kind of think that you're covering
all of your bases training in an
intermediate reprimand certainly by the
time you are approaching the point of
failure all of your motor units will
have been recruited and especially if
you're talking about more like the lower
intensity end of that range so maybe
like sets of ten to fifteen that maybe
getting to the point where it's where
it's light enough that you kind of have
some motor units cycling in and out
which which can be indicative of the
fact that you're type one fibers that
you've recruited initially in the set
may have like to reach the point of
failure and more motor units need to be
cycled in to pick up the slack so so
essentially everything is everything's
come into the party everything is being
exposed to some level of fatigue in the
process so I think I just don't think
you need to worry about specific Tibor
fiber type specific hypertrophy to any
meaningful degree and in five years from
now there may be a lot more research and
I'll have to eat my words and and we
will have a very clear view of fiber
type specific hypertrophy based on
different training parameters but we're
just not there yet and I I'm skeptical
that it occurs to a large enough degree
for 99% of people to need to worry about
okay so our next question here is from
James Wilson RN C BIA the question is
when on when on a calorie restriction
what does the research say in terms of
muscle loss and training approach
question mark intensity over volume
question mark volume over intensity
question mark or just make sure you keep
the weights the same on the bar question
mark so essentially when you're when
you're in a calorie deficit how should
you train to try to minimize muscle loss
should you try to prioritize volume or
should you try to prioritize intensity
more what's gonna give you the best bang
for your buck for for maintaining muscle
master in a cut yes so I mean this is
kind of the name of the game when it
comes to bodybuilding and you know
physique and those types of competitions
where you want to lose fat which means
you're going to be in the deficit and
you're trying to hold on to
much muscle as you realistically can
this is also one of those areas where
smart people will actually still
disagree you know there's a lot of
topics that pretty much everybody in the
evidence-based fitness world they're
going to agree on it because there's a
pretty decent amount of literature from
which to draw conclusions and usually
when we're in that case people can
pretty much just sort out what is what
is the literature say and there's
usually some lingering kind of tertiary
questions that exist but it's pretty
much agreed on this is one of those
questions where there's not a ton
because it's a pretty specialized
instance of we've got people who are
already muscular and strong they're
going into this deficit and there are
there are studies looking at like how do
we maintain aerobic fitness adaptations
on reduced volume or or by scaling
things back same thing in strength
significantly less when it comes to
straight-up muscle mass now an analogous
situation is looking at aerobic training
adaptations and what you see is to build
up a really solid base of aerobic
fitness you pretty much have to put in
the mileage you you got to do the volume
to get up to it to a pretty legit base
of aerobic fitness but what we also find
is during periods of D training if you
maintain a little bit of high intensity
effort even with a drastically reduced
volume you actually do a pretty good job
retaining a lot of those adaptations
that were built by volume there are also
studies showing that when it comes to
strength outcomes during times of
substantially reduced activity or
training volume even just a little bit
of high-intensity work can help preserve
a lot of the strength adaptations
whereas if you didn't include that
high-intensity work the D training would
have happened substantially more more
rapidly I am inclined to believe that
muscle mass probably follows a similar
pattern that you know in an ideal world
you would maintain your volume and your
intensity but that's not going to happen
for for 99% of people so the question is
what's going to give is it going to be
your training volume or is it going to
be your intensity because of those other
patterns with different types of
training adaptations I'm inclined to
believe that muscle mass would follow a
similar kind of pattern but more
importantly when I think of you know the
extreme when you're deep into a contest
prep
what are you realistically going to be
able to do so if you're deep in contest
prep are very far into a weight loss
diet or you just have a very large
caloric deficit glycogen depletion is
your life now like this is who you are
and how your life exists like you do not
have the glycogen to dig in for several
sets of 12 to 15 reps they're not going
to happen and if you talk to somebody
who's been on kind of like a in a pretty
depleted state whether it's acutely or
chronically it's the damnedest thing but
you're doing these sets and you're like
okay time to crank out 12 and you get to
seven and they're just gone and you
don't have that normal like acidosis
burn that's kind of telling you okay the
sets about to end
it's just gone and so you it's pretty
wild when you it's almost like the
lifters equivalent of bonking or hitting
the wall you hear a lot of endurance
athletes say once their glycogen
depletes it's like they feel like they
ran into a brick wall there's a very
similar thing when you're in a pretty
depleted state so when I structure my
training for you know either when I'm
chronically or even acutely severely
depleted I try to account for the fact
that you know glycogen depletion is
probably going to be there and there's
some really cool research showing that
glycogen even if you're not fully
glycogen depleted glycogen depletion
happens in a non-uniform manner and
there are different localized regions
within the muscle cell where glycogen
gets stored and when we deplete glycogen
it seems to get depleted most readily or
you know the first
storage of glycogen to go from muscle is
the storage that occurs right near the
sarcoplasmic reticulum and so when we
initiate a muscle contraction the
sarcoplasmic reticulum let go of a bunch
of calcium which is really the key
cellular event dictating the the
generation of muscular force so once
that glycogen gets depleted it looks
like that starts to interfere with
calcium release which interferes with
force production which is you no longer
completing reps basically well in in
something else
you said there was interesting so you
said that like it's just gone before
like the acidosis burden starts setting
in yeah the second site of glycogen
depletion is the intra my afib roller
stores of glycogen so essentially like
if you need to shift into anaerobic
glycolysis to get some quick ATP to your
your myosin heads that's the second
thing to go so like calcium handling
starting to go down a downhill slide
that's not good and then not even being
to get being able to get ATP like to the
myosin ATPase like that's also not good
and so it's so like yeah those are those
are the two like primary driving things
determining like can i maintain force
output during a set and and regardless
of how depleted you are like those are
the first places glycogen goes from and
if you're generally glycogen depleted
you just have less work you can do
before those two localized glycogen
stores are gone right and so for me I
think based on the evidence available
and based on the theoretical rationale I
tried to say basically how can I try to
preserve some decent amount of training
volume while not being overly reliant on
glycogen stores that realistically
aren't going to be there for me to lean
on and so what that ends up looking like
is essentially slashing the volume a
little bit primarily by shifting toward
lower rep ranges and the goal is that in
process of doing that theoretically you
can at least say well volume has has
been cut a little bit but I'm still
lifting some reasonably heavy loads so
that's always been my approach to it and
I have heard people argue the
alternative and they've basically said
well and all that heavy lifting when
you're really really depleted you're
probably gonna get hurt you're probably
not going to be able to recover from it
but I think the lesser of two evils
would be to let some of that basically
cut out the real high rep stuff so shift
toward lower rep ranges and if you're
absolutely dying like way late and prep
then you start getting into slashing
some of the some of the BS accessory
volume that realistically isn't doing a
ton for you so my short answer is I try
to cut out any kind of volume that's not
really really making major contributions
so if I can just slide in here with a
sweltering hot take oh boy I I kind of
think so so one I think something we
both have to acknowledge is there's no
research on this whatsoever
right the one of the reasons this is
such a topic of debate is shockingly I
would say of the many questions that
have been investigated in the exercise
science literature whether higher volume
or higher intensity training is better
for maintaining muscle mass during a
calorie deficit with like a chronic
training study setup no one has ever
done that before so it is so contentious
because we don't have like direct
evidence to fall back on and say like
well look someone did this study and
here's what they found so kind of my
sweltering hot take is one of the things
you see with calorie deficits and and
this is coming from just general
training studies when people are in
deficits and also from like the numerous
case studies that have been done on
natural bodybuilders and natural
physique athletes
it seems like people are more or less
fine and can maintain muscle mass just
fine going from like normal body fat
levels to normal levels of leanness and
then just like when people go from lean
to super lean everyone just loses muscle
like it's pretty much inevitable and so
I I kind of think that I kind of think
that as long as you're doing something
to maintain a stimulus to maintain some
of that muscle mass you have left you're
you're basically covering your bases and
past that point like some of the muscles
gonna go but you're maintaining a
stimulus to hold on to some and like the
details of that stimulus probably don't
matter too much and when I heard your
answer it sounded like you were more
describing the type of training you
could get in and still feel good about
without just like hitting a wall and
[ __ ] just falling off super super hard
whereas like just purely in terms of
what's going to to present your muscles
of stimulus I mean if you did a weight
that you could typically do for a set of
15 and you do like 15 9 4 or something
like that because you hit that wall I
still think you'd probably be giving
your muscles inadequate stimulus you
would just kind of feel shittier about
it and and so I see the question more as
like what type of training can you do
and maintain and feel good about to
maintain some level of stimulus versus
specifically what that stimulus is I
could see that that being the case this
is one of those questions that you hear
really you hear really experienced
bodybuilders and scientists kind of
argue about it in that weird circle of
like for people who are competitive
bodybuilders to give a damn about how
this question but but yeah I mean I
don't think there's a clear-cut answer I
do think that at the end of the day it's
getting in there and
something that's hard and not a complete
waste of your time and I think it's the
waste of your time factor we're like
you're right realistically in that
scenario it's probably a fine stimulus
but it does feel pretty stupid to pick
up a very lightweight and do four so so
I think it's almost like preserving some
kind of semblance of like tricking
yourself into thinking this that's gonna
matter you know what I mean like I'm
doing good work here yeah but uh but
yeah that that's that would be my
approach to that particular question I
know a lot of smart people who would
disagree with me and that's totally fine
next question is from Patrick he says
what is the best training approach for
explosive athletes I train parkour and
freerunning I've been doing some
complementary weight training in the gym
it'd be interesting to hear your opinion
on building a strong base for a
discipline like parkour which is mainly
explosive and jumping and stuff like
that that's a good question so there
there are several things to consider
here one is this so a common approach
which I don't think is the best approach
is when you're talking about explosive
stuff you're you're primarily talking
about power output in different planes
and primarily they're you're talking
about building up to the highest take
all philosophy possible on jumps which
which is correlated with the power
output but isn't exactly the same as
power output but anyway so one of the
common approaches you'll see and and
this is one of the reasons why there's a
ton of research published on this is
people will argue like oh that's power
output so principle of specificity like
let's apply this here let's find what
loads are associated with the highest
power outputs and let's train with those
loads and that therefore will increase
the power output and explosiveness and
yeah there's dozens of studies with
different exercises and different
populations like looking to see like oh
if we plot power with respect to
intensity where
do we see like the peak in like the
power intensity curve and usually it's
like kind of very intermediate intensity
so anywhere from I've seen as low as 30%
one rep max for some exercises but that
that's quite on the low end but
generally somewhere in like the 40 to 70
percent one rep max ranges is where
power output is maximized so people say
Oh
principle of specificity like that's
that's where we're gonna Train
there's more recent research looking
more at training your weakness on the
force velocity spectrum so essentially
if you plotted the relationship between
force output and velocity it's going to
be like a straight line with a negative
slope such that as as force output
increases velocity decreases and vice
versa and power output is going to be
maximized somewhere in the middle of
that curve being being the product of
those two factors and one of the things
we see is like that line is pretty much
just straight like that that force
velocity continuum and so rather than
training for power which is in the
middle of that line what you would have
better bang for your buck doing is
figuring out which end of that line is
holding you back and kind of pull on
that end of the line and so if you're
strong but generally slow like if you're
if you're a maximal velocity with no
load isn't great then you would do more
like pure velocity stuff so we're
talking body weight like plyometrics
maybe really really light weights maybe
even like lightened type stuff so we're
talking like using something like a
reverse band set up to jump with less
than your body weight so you can achieve
higher takeoff velocities so training
the very far extreme velocity into that
spectrum versus if someone is already
quite fast but weak then you would try
to pull out on the string
and of that curve and try to get them
stronger and so essentially this this
would make more sense if this was like
in video format or like in an article
but isn't you do movements and all in
their rate with extreme detail I'll try
to do it so you have like ideally you
want to have a line that is sloping down
that intersects both the X and y axis at
a 45 degree angle such that it forms a
right triangle if there is a shallower
slope meaning that force is high but
velocity is low you want to pull up on
the side of that line that's on the y
axis to kind of even it out more or if
it's more of a steeper slope so that
peak velocity is high but peak forces
low you want to pull out on the line
where it intersects the x axis to
increase force output what both of those
things are going to do is increase like
the elevation in the middle part of that
line where power output is maximized and
that therefore increases explosive
performance and this isn't just
theoretical like there's research
looking at this so when we profile
people and we identify the low force
people versus the low velocity people
and we put them on a program that's
tailored to training the extreme end of
that force velocity spectrum where they
suck compared to a group of people who
are just put on like a high power
program where which is training like the
middle part of that relationship the
people who are put on a program that is
specific to where they're bad have
larger increases in power output and
jump height than the folks who train
with loads that actually maximize power
output so yeah that that is the first
thing I would look at just kind of
profile yourself and I could we could we
could link a paper in the show notes
that details how you would go about
doing that and kind of give some back up
to to what I've just been rambling about
but yeah so profile yourself figure out
what you're bad at if you're strong but
slow work on increasing peak velocity if
you're
fast but we just work on getting
stronger and that's probably going to
give you the most bang for your buck
second thing is for someone doing
parkour or really anything that's like
heavily heavily plyometric like that one
thing you need to potentially be
concerned about is injury risk because
when you're coming down from extreme
Heights and trying to absorb that force
you need a tremendous amount of
eccentric strength to do that so I
wouldn't I think it would probably be a
pretty good idea to do like eccentric
training like eccentric overload
training just to make sure you have like
a big enough eccentric strength reserve
that you can one like acutely keep
yourself safe and not sustain an acute
injury but chronically to to reduce some
of the wear and tear of that rapid
eccentric loading I find that the - I
find that the easiest way to get like
eccentric overload stuff is just doing
stuff in a gym with a partner and either
you load a lot of weight and like your
partner helps you get the weight up and
then you lower it yourself eccentric ly
under control or the other way around
where you have a generally light weight
that you're lifting and you lift it up
yourself and then your partner like
pushes down on the way down - to cause
an eccentric overload or if you're by
yourself a lot of exercises allow you to
do the concentric with like both limbs
and the eccentric with just one limb so
take a knee extension for example you
could do the eccentric part with just
one leg and then use both legs to kick
back up to the top for the concentric to
essentially allow you to to lift heavier
weights than you typically would be able
to with just one leg and get some
eccentric overload so I think that
regardless of which side of the force
velocity spectrum you fall on getting
some specific like eccentric overload
work would probably be a pretty good
idea for longevity but in terms of pure
performance the the force philosophy
profiling stuff
is very very clutch find what you're bad
at and focus on improving that and that
that's probably what's going to give you
the most bang for your buck and it's
gonna be different person-to-person you
know I would say in the strength &
Conditioning world specificity is one of
those things where you find people kind
of missing the mark on both sides of the
spectrum so there's like there's like a
small but somewhat vocal group of people
who it's like listen if you squat heavy
sets of five surely you'll be physically
prepared for whatever life might throw
at you you know like they're they can
clean up non-specific just if you if you
can squat pull and press well you're
gonna be fine and for a lot of sports
and activities that just doesn't make
sense and then there's the other side of
the spectrum where people are like
obsessed with specificity and so they're
like well whatever my actual activity is
I'm just going to load it and so what
they act inadvertently do is make an
explosive athletic movement into a slow
trained to be slow slightly more
resistant movement yet again is not
helpful like when you see somebody doing
like weight resisted punches just
training themselves to punch slowly well
I mean so so like it depends if the
loading is small enough that it's just
introducing like a small change like
that can be good so like a classic
example here is like resisted Sprint's
if you just load a little weight on a
weight sled and sprint against it that
that can help people improve speed or if
on the opposite side of things if you
want to do like downhill sprinting for
over speed work like a slight decline
can be good but yeah sometimes people
can take it too far and it's like okay
let's sprint down a 30-degree incline or
let's load up like 400 pounds on a
pulling sled and pull it at four miles
an hour and say it's speed training
right yeah moving on this is a really
controversial one I'm kind of hesitant
to get on the topic zach asks us does
pineapple belong on pizza
what do you think Greg oh for sure
really yeah are you against pineapple
and pizza
I mean and by the way for those who are
listening if you don't know this Greg is
definitely the culinary expert of the
the team here he's quite an expert in
the kitchen honestly my thing about
pineapple on pizza is I think that
people should have the freedom and the
right to put pineapple on a pizza but I
don't want anything to do with it III
don't like any sweet ingredients being
and there's too much moisture too too
sweet too much moisture so one I think
it depends kind of what your what's your
idea of a pizza is I mean it it could be
a utterly ludicrous proposition if you
have the idea of pizza that's like a
traditional Italian pizza
that's just like sauce cheese and like
maybe basil and the sauce also isn't
super traditional a lot of times it's
just cheese and basil and sometimes it's
it's literally just sauce like that that
is a traditional thing as well yeah so
really when you're getting two toppings
past that then then you're already
getting away from a lot of what a lot of
people's like Platonic ideal of a pizza
is but I think if you're talking about
like Americanized pizza I don't think
there's anything that particularly
strange about it like essentially you're
you're trying to balance some sweetness
with some savoriness often with like a
little bit of heat as well you know a
little bit of red pepper flake a little
bit of heat from like charcuterie and so
like with and especially like if we're
talking like just straight-up like
American pizza oftentimes you're dealing
with a pretty sweet tomato sauce like a
traditional tomato sauce is typically
like literally just tomato sometimes
tomato and like a little basil garlic a
little salt maybe a little olive oil but
certainly any sweetness that's gonna
come from it is just going to be from
the tomato most American tomato sauces
you'd put on a pizza are pretty heavily
sweetened already and so you have like
more of an aggressive interplay between
like sweetness and saltiness already
between the salt and the cheese and so
like yeah I think it just depends on the
style of pizza like what I put pineapple
on a Neapolitan pizza with like just
plain tomato sauce and like a little
mozzarella and some basil and [ __ ]
pineapple he'll know that it doesn't
work in that context at all yeah but if
you're talking like what you're gonna
get in most American pizza joints like
it fits right in like it adds another
sweet element to the dish especially if
you're balancing it off of like the most
common thing it would be paired with is
is Canadian bacon which is like that
adds another salty element balanced out
by the sweet element of the pineapple
like I don't I don't think in that
context it's that out of left field so
just to give context
my pizza background most of the pizzas
I've bought in my life came from a place
in Columbus Ohio that operated out of a
gas station so maybe I just wasn't
getting the most fresh pineapple maybe
that's the problem
wait you were getting like frozen
pineapple I don't know well first of all
I wasn't ordering it there but I I don't
have faith that that would have been a
fun experience oh oh I gotcha I gotcha
yeah now on to an actual somewhat
relevant food question Pedro asks
chicken wings thighs or breasts and I
know we're gonna disagree on this so so
I know Pedro and I feel like I know what
Pedro would say me and my wife and Cody
Lefever actually stayed at Pedro's place
for a night in San Diego back when I
lived in California and he took us on
just an utterly fantastic bar crawl of
San Diego like we start we started
drinking probably a
I am and were added until like late that
night and San Diego is such a good beer
town anyway that makes me tired just
hearing that it was great like I'm so
old that when I hear the concept of
drinking for like 13 hours I'm like
already sleepy no I mean like for me
it's one of those things that like if
I'm gonna do it I'm probably not gonna
drink for like the next month because
like it's just the concept of beer stops
being appealing yeah um oh yeah from
time to time I think it's fun anyways so
we got to his place the night before and
when we arrived he made us some
lemongrass wings which were fantastic so
based on that experience and and due to
how good he is at cooking wings I feel
like Pedro is a wing guy and my personal
answer here is it kind of depends on the
preparation method so I like chicken I
eat a lot of chicken if I'm going to eat
chicken in like a degenerate way where
it's like I'm eating this purely for the
like hedonic pleasure that comes from it
I'm definitely going with wings if I'm
doing meal prep and I want something
that's like reasonably healthy and easy
to cook and I can make a lot of it and
it's still going to be like tasty in my
fridge after being in there for like
five or six days then it's gonna be
thighs like boneless skinless thighs are
good like they're certainly not as lean
as a breast but like they're pretty lean
like they're they're leaner than most
cuts of lean beef which I don't think a
lot of people realize they hold on to
moisture really well they're really easy
to grill without drying out they're
really easy to bake without drying out
they keep really well in the fridge of
the three options I definitely eat more
thighs than anything else but then if
I'm being like really bougie and making
like a chicken meal for myself and my
wife my go-to is probably going to be
like a spatchcock roasted chicken or
maybe like a whole smoked chicken and
when you do it up like that the breast
can be abs
luli fantastic if you're cooking it low
and slow or especially smoking it low
and slow and like the fat from under the
skin can seep into the breast and you
spatchcock it so what that means is you
just cut the spine out of the bird so
you can like lay it down flat so it
cooks a little faster you can you can
keep it in gentle heat not for an
incredibly long amount of time so the
breast is still lean but you don't cook
the water out of it so it's still like
really moist and when I'm actually gonna
take the time to make roast chicken I
think I actually prefer the breast to
the thigh so yeah
much like the pizza answer just kind of
context dependent and in what you're
trying to get out of the chicken and how
you feel like cooking it and how much
effort you feel like putting into
cooking it
I'm glad you ended with the effort part
so anyone who knows me knows that as a
bodybuilder I'm not big I'm not
particularly muscular but the thing that
allows me to get by in bodybuilding is
that I'm very lazy in the kitchen and I
have impossibly low food standards so
for me chicken wings thighs or breasts
always breasts put it in the crock-pot
come back to it some number of days
later and it is cooked and here's what
you can do Gregg you want an exciting
Italian meal what'd you put in it is
excuse me what you pay shredded chicken
with a marinara sauce and a light layer
of mozzarella cheese on top you got an
Italian dinner now if you wanted to have
like a Mexican night a shredded chicken
some diced peppers and you put some
salsa on top it's really kind of a
shredded chicken breast is the canvas
upon which you paint a meal and with the
right canned sauce or condiment you can
go wild you can make that meal whatever
you needed to be and I am genuinely not
kidding I've had tacos for lunch every
day for the last problem
six weeks and sometimes when I'm feeling
very spicy I will put riced
beets in my my shredded chicken tacos
that's about as that's about as wild as
I get so yeah if you're out there and
you're thinking if you heard Greg's
answer and you're like god that sounds
like a lot of work don't do that don't
do that just make a make chicken breast
in a crock-pot you're gonna be fine I
mean it's not that hard to roast a
chicken it's just like it's a little
more work to spatchcock it but like it's
still not hard I had never heard that
word until three minutes ago when you
said it it's just like it's just a
classy way of saying you take some
kitchen shears and cut the spine out on
this thing that sounds morbid if I spend
more than 15 minutes putting a meal
together it's because somebody
interrupted me for five minutes but
anyway that I very much respect how
skilled you are in the kitchen and the
time you put into it
and I very much enjoy that I get to reap
the rewards of that every Sunday night
when we have dinner but anyway there's
two very different opinions none of
which are evidence-based about how you
should make your chicken purchases okay
next question is from Alex if I have to
cut weight for a powerlifting meet
what's the best way to go about it in
terms of performance let's say I'm ten
pounds over and I have 16 weeks to go
it's probably a good spot to be in
option one slow cut a pound per week is
starting about eight to ten weeks out
so basically chill for a while and then
just do a pound a week leading into the
show option to do that cut the first
eight to ten weeks and then just
maintain weight going into the show and
then option three would be just chill
for fifteen minutes and do a big water
cut at the end I'll take a crack a crack
at this and that I want to hear your
thoughts on it after Greg my my thing
about water cuts my concern is you you
don't want to just throw that in not
knowing how you perform mm-hmm in that
context so there are some people that
can do a sizable water cut and still
perform pretty well everybody's got a
number
that it's like if I water cut X number
of pounds I'm fine if I cut X plus one
I'm done like I'm screwed yeah so you
you want to make sure that it's almost
like with bodybuilding with a peak week
strategy you never want to try it the
first time when it matters so um
generally speaking I don't advocate
particularly large water cuts and that
that goes back to when I coached
wrestlers
I didn't like my wrestlers doing large
water cuts and I often just advised
against them so with powerlifting it
depends on your body size it depends how
well you can accommodate water cuts but
for me if I was a person competing early
and it depends whether you're doing a
meet with a two-hour weigh in or a 24
hour weigh in absolutely cuz those are
very different beasts absolutely with a
24 hour way and there is a lot of
flexibility yeah if you get away with a
lot if someone wants to cut ten pounds
may have a 24 hour way in [ __ ] be my
guess man like it that's not gonna be a
fun water cut but like pretty much
everyone's gonna be able to pull it off
you got plenty of time to even rehydrate
like you'll be fine a 10 pound water cut
with a two-hour weigh-in whoo buddy no
like that yeah that's gonna suck and you
might be fine later in the day by the
time deadlifts roll around but like
squats aren't gonna go well if your
water cutting that much yeah now the the
one the the approach here that I would
probably be least fond of you know the
water cut again we already talked about
the factors that go into whether or not
that's an advisable approach obviously
don't do anything stupid don't get
yourself hurt don't end up in the
hospital I don't I'm not fond of the
idea of cutting for the first eight to
ten weeks and then just staying there
for a while I to me that's kind of the
worst of both worlds you you took the
time and patience to go through the cut
and then you just waited therefore for 8
to 10 weeks and we're kind of miserable
in my opinion that's kind of the
probably the least advisable approach
what I would often do for most
class sports is generally do a slow cut
until you get within your comfortable
striking distance for a water cut so
like for me if I were to compete around
you know 180 pounds I personally
wouldn't want to do a water cut of more
than like three to five pounds so what I
would do is I would do a nice slow cut
and I would time it up so it's nice
gradual linear weight loss and kind of
shoot for within you know maybe two
weeks of the meet getting to my my
comfortable weight that puts me in
striking distance I would do it two
weeks before to just give myself some
wiggle room because you know sometimes
things happen and body weight is
annoying and you're like oh I didn't get
there in time so my approach would be
generally do a nice comfortable linear
drop and once you get to that place
where you're within a water cut striking
distance I would just chill there but I
wouldn't plan to get there too far out
ahead because now you're just holding
weight that you know it's not your
natural weight it's not the weight that
you enjoy being at yeah I think that I
think that's another key consideration
like you mentioned natural weight I
think that another important
consideration is where you see yourself
being weight wise after the meet and so
for example if you're you know if you
weigh something and it's heavier than
you would ideally like to be and you're
thinking like you know I want to move
down a weight class and stay there and
maybe eventually move down to weight
classes because I have a considerable
amount of fat to cut then I would
approach that differently then you know
if if you're like quite competitive and
you're natural walking around weight is
215 but you compete at 205 in
powerlifting then you know after the
meet you're probably going to be getting
back up to 215 and so you you probably
don't want to cut early and maintain an
unnatural weight for multiple weeks
leading into the meet which which is far
away from where you feel good and
comfortable and then
you know have to move back up after that
so if someone is like actually trying to
decrease weight and wants to be like at
the weight that their meat is at or
below that weight for you know in
indefinite period of time after the meat
then I would say go ahead and take care
of the cut on the front end and go with
that that option to the slow cut for the
first eight to ten weeks and then
maintenance after that because you know
then at that point kind of your true
body weight is the competition weight
and if you want to keep moving lower
after that you know then you're kind of
taking what amounts to like a six week
diet break competing at the top of that
weight class and then continuing to move
down after that that's a good point
because I answered under the assumption
that that you are not now just assuming
a new body weight yeah I was under the
assumption that you're going back to
normal after the meat
yeah for sure or in and if if that is
the case like if the way to compete at
is below what your natural body weight
is and you're planning on getting back
up to your natural weight after you
compete then I very very much agree with
what treck said okay moving on to the
next one from Alex when you have pain
during a certain exercise how do you
decide whether it's worth spending lots
of time and effort rehabbing that
movement / body part versus just picking
a different variation or an exercise for
the same muscle group that produces no
pain so basically you're doing an
exercise and it's bothering you it's
causing you pain how do you decide when
it's worth figuring it out and rehabbing
your way through it versus just cutting
and and moving on to something else
to me at least it kind of depends what
you're doing that movement for so for
example for me I'm a power lifter my
sport is squat bench deadlift and so
like if squats caused me pain I still
have to squat you know like like just
hand them a note says I I don't go quite
to parallel but it's fine I my hip hurts
yeah I mean so at that point like if the
move
is your sport or part of your sport then
you got a troubleshoot and figure out
how to do it in a more comfortable way
maybe you would sub in like some some
clothes accessory exercises that are
going to cause you less discomfort like
in day to day life but also still do
that exercise that causes you discomfort
often enough that you can put up a good
number on the platform but you're kind
of you're kind of backed into a corner
we're like you got to do what you got to
do if on the other hand you're not a
power lifter you know maybe you're just
a general strength enthusiast or maybe
you're a bodybuilder or physique athlete
then like dude there's no exercises you
have to have to do if there's an
exercise that you just love and it
causes you discomfort you know then you
may want to troubleshoot it a little bit
certainly go to a physical therapist to
see if they can help you out but if you
don't have like an emotional attachment
to a particular exercise like just move
on to something that's more comfortable
see I think it I think the answer to
that question really strongly depends on
why you're doing it in the first place
like for me like bench press hurts I
have like an old shoulder problem like
my right shoulder is bone-on-bone bench
press always hurts but it's a third of
my sports like I got to do it and
there's really no weight to make it not
hurt so it's like yeah I just got to
suck it up but like where I not power
lifting I probably never bench press
again because there would be other ways
to accomplish the same general
adaptations of like PEC and tricep
hypertrophy and general pressing
strength so yeah yeah like if you don't
have to do it just just sub something
else in if there's something else that
accomplishes the same purpose and is
more comfortable if you do have to do it
then you know you troubleshoot go to a
physical therapist and try to figure out
a way to make it a little better yeah I
mean I I totally agree the clients that
I coach I always tell them we simply
don't do accessory lifts that cause pain
period if you're doing an accessory lift
and you feel pain you cut it you know
it's it's just not at all worth it to me
now if it's like a primary movement that
we've really programmed that training
block around then it gets more into are
we doing this because it was just plan a
or is it because we compete in it if we
don't compete in it we can probably find
a very suitable comfortable replacement
so the the only time that you ever
really have to get serious and get back
to the drawing board and figure out like
we need to make this work is if you are
literally going to compete in that exact
lift for everything else it's negotiable
all right so we've got a couple couple
more questions to get to Dan writes I
would love to hear you guys discuss the
one or two things that you feel
contributed most to your success in
powerlifting slash bodybuilding be it a
mindset aspect of training aspect of
nutrition etc you can you can lead off
on this one success in so I I haven't
had any success in powerlifting so I'm
gonna punt on that aspect I assume the
bodybuilding part is for me I think I
want to preface this by saying I'm by no
means a remarkable or a successful
bodybuilder but I'm doing my best and I
think one of the things that's allowed
me to stick with it over a long period
of time is first of all there's gotta be
a lot of passion there a bodybuilding is
something that's intrigued me for a long
time and I started lifting when I was 12
and just absolutely fell in love with it
so even if I didn't compete in power
lift bodybuilding I would still probably
lift a cell at four or five times a week
in perpetuity bodybuilding for me was
just an outlet to be competitive and
actually feel like it wasn't ridiculous
that I was spending so much time in the
gym the only thing that I would say
actually makes me successful in
bodybuilding I already mentioned this
episode
I could be completely satisfied living
the rest of my life eating only chicken
spinach and maybe a small assortment of
condiments and spices
the one thing that's always intrigued me
in the bodybuilding world is Dexter
Jackson Dexter Jackson if you're not
familiar ifbb pro bodybuilder the lead
the blade is his nickname he won in
Olympia and I'm always perplexed of like
how is he
always in perfect shape always so so
lean every single time if you go to
Wikipedia and you look at his
competition history it is astounding
he's been competing for a hundred and
eleven years and it's like every
competition he's top three against the
best in the world yeah and honestly like
that that is the defining thing about
Dexter Jackson like he's he's never been
the biggest guy on stage but like the
the only thing standing between him and
winning shows is like the guys that are
bigger than him do they come in and
shape if they don't come in and shape
it's a free win because he's always in
shape he will be like he and I do it's
like like you said he's been competing
for over a hundred years
um it's correct every year you're like
this is gonna be the year he falls off
yeah it's not he's he's quite old and
especially by like pro bodybuilding
terms like those guys don't have a long
shelf life typical they don't but like
dude's been at it forever and he brings
a great package
every single time like always on point
yeah but I remember you and I ages ago
we're discussing Dexter Jackson and we
were just kind of like what the hell is
he this good always perfect and you
basically put forth the theory that he
is just most capable of him what
bodybuilders call embracing the suck you
know when you're deep into a preparation
for a competition this is going to suck
and your food choices are gonna suck and
you're gonna be tired and lethargic and
you're not gonna feel good and a
large part of success in bodybuilding is
how do you would face that challenge
physically there's there's really no
choices to be made but kind of more
mentally are are you comfortable with
that and can you find some weird kind of
fascination with it and so for me being
a person who studies physiology I think
it's wild I I think it's kind of cool to
be honest it doesn't that doesn't make
it feel any better but if I were to say
there's anything that got me from being
an absolute trash bodybuilder to an okay
bodybuilder it's the fact that loving it
keeps me in the gym having absolutely no
food standards keeps my diet pretty
alright and then the fact that I
genuinely have a fascination with all
the crazy stuff that happens late in
prep when your body is essentially like
shutting down basically there's a few
ways to view that not many of them are
good but I think if you can somehow find
a way to get some kind of fascination
from it it makes it slightly more
tolerable and you can embrace it and
that's that's pretty much it for me
fair for me and this probably isn't the
answer that the Dan was looking for I
mean like genetics like so I mean the
the dirty secret here is that everyone
who has attained a high level of success
in any sport was very genetically gifted
for it and like I mean I know how much
work I've put in to get good at
powerlifting but 99 plus percent of
people could do the exact same stuff
I've done and not ever lift the weights
that I've lifted so like yeah dude like
I picked good parents and and I can
admit that to myself and anyone who has
attained like a similar level of success
or more success that says that like who
won't admit that like
having a really good genetic draw was a
major part of that they aren't
necessarily lying to you because they
very well could believe the things that
they're saying but they're mistaken like
here they're either lying to you or or
they're wrong but any more innocent way
so yeah like I mean that that's the
biggest thing by far and then past that
I think one of the things that has
helped me is like I'm a little crazy and
don't really give that much of a [ __ ]
about anything in the gym and the times
that I've made the most progress have
tended to be the times that I've just
had like some wild idea and it's like
well I don't know of anyone else doing
this so let's give it a shot so like
when I went from being like a good
lifter to like a quite good lifter was
when I tried like Bulgarian style
training for the first time it's like
inspired by a bazhaev's system he did
with his weight lifters and so I was
working up to a max on some sort of
squat and some sort of bench twice a day
every day and then doing like
bodybuilding or like athletic type work
most days of the week as well like in a
third workout and like I was told that
that was bad and that I'd hurt myself
and burn out but like one of the things
that helps me is like I'm a power lifter
because I like lifting heavy [ __ ] and
Maxine is like the ultimate way of
lifting heavy [ __ ] and so when I saw
like oh there's a training system that
revolves around Maxine all the time like
hell yeah sign me up like let me give
this a shot and like I've never I can't
think of a time that I've loaded a
weight on the bar that's that scared me
and I think that that's a big thing as
well I think I think a lot of people
have mental blocks where they'll unrack
something and I'll feel really
heavy in their hands or feel really
heavy on their back and like they've
just failed before they even attempt the
lift like it just gets in their head or
like they'll get scared of just seeing a
weight on the bar and realistically like
honestly that just doesn't happen to me
the closest thing I can think of was
when I was messing around one time with
I was using a heavy band setup like a
slingshot and like if you guys don't
know this before like slingshots were a
thing people did like literally the
exact same thing but they would just
take like a resistance band and like
double it over and put it around their
arms and it accomplished the same thing
as a slingshot but Marc Bell found a way
to like make a product for that and
monetize it so good for him but yeah
like a heavy band is going to give you a
lot more assistance than a slingshot
will so I was playing around with that
one day and I mostly only used like the
medium bands and with those I I would
work up somewhere and like the low to
mid 500s but I put a heavy band on and
got up like a little over six and like
that just wasn't a weight I touched
before so like when that was lifted out
to me and I felt it in my hands I could
like feel the bones in my forearm flex a
little bit and that scared me so he felt
your bones bowing under the pressure
dude like that's that's a thing it's not
like super common but occasionally
you'll see like multi ply bench pressors
like their forearm just snap in the
middle of a lift in like they're
generally safe because they work up to
those really heavy weights like
gradually over time but I went from like
never having touched more than like
maybe five thirty to like let's load six
on the bar and so my bones were not
adapted to that type of stress and and
and that's literally the only time I can
think of that I've even been like a
little bit afraid of a weight and so
like like I picked I picked good parents
like everyone on my mom's side of the
family's like
super-strong like whatever I did I was
bound to at least have some level of
success in powerlifting and then I I
just don't have like the mental blocks
affecting me that affect a lot of people
cuz like I'm a little bit crazy and
weights just don't scare me like it's
either gonna go up or it's not and
especially after doing Bulgarian like I
failed so many lifts that like I know
how to bail I'm not gonna hurt myself
failing at lifts like what's there to be
afraid of you know yeah back in my
powerlifting days I would bail on squats
all the time I failed on squats all the
time at like a commercial campus gym and
every time it was like the people around
me very well-intentioned thought it was
like a catastrophe every time it
happened I'm like dude this just how it
is now like I'm just stupid so I fail
all the time it's alright so I you know
I understood their concern and I
appreciated it because it was in you
know good intentions like dude you okay
and like yeah I just drop bars a lot
yeah now when you were doing the the
Bulgarian method those three sessions a
day how much time were you spending in
the gym everyday like the whole
literally the whole day so I was working
at nationally performance at the time
and there there would occasionally be
some people like coming in throughout
the day for like one-on-ones but the the
big times are like in the morning like
adults would come in before work and
then the main the main coaching I was
doing is like group coaching for like
youth and like high school and some
collegiate athletes and they would be
coming in from like three to six 6:30
give or take and so I would go in at
like 10:00 and like get a workout in
from 10:00 to like 11:30 and then just
like rest a little bit heat a little bit
start warming up again
like 115 and finish up just before 3:00
like before the 3 o'clock session was
about to start and then I coach from
like 3 to 6:30 and then some days like
the coaches would get like a group
workout in after that and that was more
just kind of like body building like
pump type stuff like get big at Jack and
sometimes my wife had an internship at a
local newspaper she would come in after
work with her sister who was training
for volleyball and so I was also like
training them and I'd be like training
them and also doing their workout along
with them so I was in the gym everyday
between training and coaching from 10
a.m. to probably about 9 p.m.
give or take and and of that time
probably maybe like five hours of it was
spent training four and a half five
hours so like all day every day so there
you have it all you have to do if you
want to be a good power lifter is take
the right parents and train about five
hours a day and you should be there in
no time you know honestly man I am
interested to see what would happen if
there was ever money in the sport of
powerlifting and people could like
legitimately do it professionally like
you know obviously there is a finite
amount of time in the day that one could
train without just like way overdoing it
and like eventually breaking down but
you know if if like there was a
nutrition staff to make sure your
nutrition was always on point and like
you didn't have to have a job because
like powerlifting was your job and so
you have like plenty of time to like
sleep and recover every night and like
you know get like massage work every day
or whatever like have a have a like
recovery facility as part of like the
power lifting team facility you could go
to and then also like have time to get
in like a solid four hours of training
every day I kind of think that numbers
would just explode
because that that is that's the only
period in my life where I've had like a
solid several months to live a lifestyle
even approximating that and during that
time I probably made so let me just
think through this real quick I put a
hundred and seventy pounds on my total
in ten eleven weeks and I've put a grand
total of about eight hundred pounds on
my total from the time I started
training so I don't know man
I made like a quarter of the total
progress I have ever made in my training
career in like a two and a half month
span when I just had a lifestyle that
was crazy conducive to just training and
recovering super well so yeah that's
just something I wonder if if my life
consisted of something approximating
like that three-month span one would I
would do and then to just in in the
sport in general what performances and
numbers would look like alright well I
tell you what if we severely slash all
of my responsibilities pertaining to
stronger by science I can start training
six hours a day and we'll see if it if
it's if it can be replicated what if we
ramped up your responsibilities related
to stronger by science and I instead did
that to see if my experience replicates
honestly I would actually prefer that I
like the work I do a hell of a lot more
than I'd like training six hours a day
alright I think that's probably a good
place to wrap it up for today now I
mention all these questions come from a
few different social media threats we've
got one on Facebook one on Twitter one
on Instagram and when you introduce
these one of our listeners Steve said
great now I have stage fright and I
can't think of anything now that he had
the opportunity to ask a question well
Steve if you're hearing
this if that stage-fright has dissipated
still feel free to ask a question we are
trying to keep those questions localized
on those three threads on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter but yeah we're
gonna keep looking back at those and
referring back to them to harvest
questions for for these Q&A shows so if
you listen to this and you liked it and
think yeah these guys seem competent
enough to answer some of the questions I
may be having feel free to stop by those
threads jot your questions down and we
will get to them eventually and we will
link those all three of those threads in
the description of this episode so keep
the questions coming and we will see you
next time thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com to
check out the products and services that
we offer thanks for listening and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you